>> Laura: ALL OF THE MEDIA ARE
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED BY THE
SUCCESS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
DESPITE 2 YEARS OF AN
INVESTIGATION THAT WENT NOWHERE.
AND NOW THEY ARE MOVING FROM AN
OBSESSION OVER IMPEACHMENT TO
THIS.
>> WE KNOW HE IS A CRIMINAL WITH
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
HERE'S THE ANSWER.
YOU CREATE A 3rd LANE.
YOU TAKE THE WORD IMPEACHMENT
AND YOU CHANGE IT TO CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
>> THE HEADLINE IS PRESIDENT
TRUMP LIKELY COMMITTED A CRIME
BUT I THINK NOT CHARGE HIM
BECAUSE SITTING PRESIDENTS COULD
NOT BE CHARGED.
>> HE MADE IT CRYSTAL CLEAR.
>> Laura: IMPEACHMENT IS NOT
GOOD ENOUGH ANYMORE.
JOINING ME IS FORMER SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE AND HOST OF A NEW POD
CAST AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
NEWT GINGRICH.
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS WILL HURT
DEMOCRATS IN 2020 IF THEY END UP
PUSHING FORWARD ON THIS?
>> SURE.
I THINK THEY WILL LOOK NUTS.
HE HIMSELF LOOKED NUTS.
YOU COME OUT AND SAY THE
RUSSIANS WE INDICTED ARE
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY.
BUT NOW THE PRESIDENT, WE HAVE
NOT PROVEN HIM INNOCENT YET.
THINK ABOUT THAT MUELLER SAID.
NOW YOU HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
SAYING MAYBE WE CAN'T IMPEACH
HIM BUT WE KNOW HE IS
A CRIMINAL?
HOW DO THEY KNOW THAT?
YOU HAVE TO START OUT WITH
A FASCIST LEFT, FREE SPEECH
MEANINGS YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
SPEAK.
IF YOU SAY ANYTHING WRONG YOU
ARE HOMOPHOBIC OR SOMETHING.
THEIR NORMAL BEHAVIOR IS TO JUST
MAKE STUFF UP.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN GUILTY OF
ANYTHING.
2 YEARS MUELLER HAD 15 LEFT
WING-DEMOCRATIC LAWYERS.
ALL VERY GOOD PROSECUTORS.
HE HAD $30 MILLION.
HE LOCKED UP AT LEAST 2 PEOPLE
IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT THAT ARE
UN-AMERICAN AND COULD NOT FIND
ANYTHING.
THE DEMOCRATS NEED TO RECOGNIZE
SHOULD A DRY HOLE.
>> Laura: THE POLICY DEAL.
EVEN SOME DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
LEFTY, ARE GETTING A LITTLE
FRUSTRATED BY THE FACT THAT WHEN
THEY ARE INVITEED TO SPEAK TO
THE MEDIA, THE POLICIES THEY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT, THEY ARE BE
ECLIPSED.
BRAD SHERMAN EXPERIENCED THIS
YESTERDAY ON MSNBC.
>> I BEEN TRYING TO TALK ABOUT
THE SAUDI NUCLEAR PROGRAM AND WE
WOULD TALK ABOUT EFFORTS TO
CONTROL DRUG PRICES.
THERE IS AN IMAGE IN THE PUBLIC
THAT THE CONGRESS IS ONLY
FOCUSSED ON IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I AM WORKING ON.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK MORE
DEMOCRATS WILL PUSH BACK ON
THIS?
THE POLLS, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
POLLS ARE GOING UP.
I GET THE SENSE TO THE FACT THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
DEBATE.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN
DEMONIZING.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
>> WE HAVE A REFERENDUM ON THE
NEWS MEDIA AND THEY LOST.
THAT'S THE NUMBER 1 THING IN THE
LAST 2 YEARS.
REALLY 3 YEARS COUNTING THE
CAMPAIGN.
TRUMP IS STILL PRESIDENT AND
IMPROVING HIS POLLS NUMBERS.
THE COUNTRY IS CLOSER TO TRUMP
THAN RADICAL DEMOCRATS.
I PREDICT YOU WILL SEE
A REPUBLICAN SENATE PASSING
LEGISLATION AND NANCY PELOSI IS
OVER HERE WITH A PARTY WHO WANTS
TO SPEND EVERY DAY ATTACKING
DONALD TRUMP AND WANTS TO PASS
SOMETHING.
I WOULD NOT BE SURPRISEED TO SEE
KEVIN MCCARTHY FORM AN ALLIANCE
WITH 40 DEMOCRATS IF THEY STAY
NEGATIVE.
>> Laura: LOOK AT ALL OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
WE ARE DOING A SERIES ON AN
UPDATE ON THE MODERATE
DEMOCRATS.
SO MANY PLEDGE TO WORK WITH
TRUMP.
PUSH COMES TO SHOVE.
NOT WORKING WITH TRUMP.
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT.
PART OF THE NEW ISSUE THAT TRUMP
IS TACKLING IS THE BORDER.
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IT FOR YEARS.
THE SITUATION IS BEYOND A CRISIS
BY ALMOST EVERY MEASURE.
WHAT ABOUT THE DECISION TO SLAP
5% TARIFFS ON MEXICO UNLESS THEY
STEM THIS MASSIVE TIDE OF
HUMANITY?
>> ONE THING THAT WILL BE PART
OF TRUMP'S LEGACY THAT
HISTORIANS WILL WRITE ABOUT IS
HE HAS COMMON SENSE AND HE
FOLLOWS PROJECTS THROUGH LIKE
THE BUSINESSMAN HE WAS.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE WOULD BE ON
THE AMERICAN BORDER IF THEY WERE
NOT COMING THROUGH MEXICO.
WITHOUT MEXICAN COMPLIANCE, ALL
OF THESE PEOPLE WOULD STILL BE
DOWN IN CENTRAL AMERICA.
I THINK IS THE FIRST TIME WE
HAVE SEEN THE AMERICAN PRESIDENT
SAY -- BY THE WAY, THE DEMOCRATS
AND CONGRESS ARE FORCING HIM
INTO THIS POSITION BECAUSE THEY
REFUSE TO DO THE COMMON SENSE
THINGS WHICH ARE FUND THE BORDER
PATROL AND BUILD THE WALL AND
ALLOW US TO CONTAIN THINGS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID IF YOU ARE
NOT GOING TO HELP ME, THEN I CAN
USE MY AUTHORITY TO PUT SO MUCH
PRESSURE ON MEXICO.
IF HE THEN MOVES TO CUT OFF
SENDING MONEY TO MEXICO, YOU
WOULD SEE AN ENORMOUS CRISIS IN
THE MEXICAN ECONOMY.
>> Laura: WE HAVE SOME
REPUBLICAN SENATES AGAINST THESE
TARIFFS.
GRASSLEY AND A LOT OF OF THE
FARMERS ARE HURT BY THE SOYBEAN
TARIFFS.
HOW MANY PAIN IS BEING INFLICTED
ON THE AMERICAN CONSUMER?
HOW LONG CAN THIS ADMINISTRATION
HOLD OUT?
I AGREE WITH WHAT THEY ARE DOING
ON TARIFFS.
I AM HEARING FROM WALL STREET
PEOPLE WHO DO A LOT OF WORK IN
CHINA, THIS IS REALLY HEARTH US.
-- HURTING US.
BECAUSE YOU ARE DOING DEALS WITH
COMMUNIST CHINA.
>> A NUMBER OF BILLIONAIRES LOVE
CHINA BECAUSE THAT'S HOW THEY
BECAME BILLION AREAS.
I -- -- I HOPE WE WILL USE THE
CHINESE TARIFFS PAYMENTS TO TAKE
CARE OF THE FARMERS WHO THE
CHINESE ARE TRYING TO RIP OFF.
IF HE DOES THAT IT WILL BECOME
A NON-ISSUE.
CHINA WILL NOT WIN A TRADE WAR
WITH THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S JUST NOT POSSIBLE.
THE CHINESE WILL BUILD
COMPETITORS IN VIETNAM AND THE
PHILIPPINES AND THEY WILL LOOK
MARKET SHARE AND WE DON'T NEED
THEM.
>> Laura: ON MOST THINGS.
THE SOYBEAN FARMERS WILL GET THE
ATTENTION ON OTHER NETWORKS.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WILL HURT
TRUMP.
OUR ECONOMY VERSUS THE CHINESE
ECONOMY, IT DOESN'T HURT US.
DO THE MATH!
>> THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT IN THE
NUMBER OF BILLION DOLLARS HE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
HE COULD AFFORD TO DOUBLE THE